gilles qui rêveriez vous de voir
derrière son rideau qui en fait vous
mettez le doute parce que je suis
persuadé que c'est dans la sphère
professionnelle donc dans la sphère
professionnelle il ya des gens que
j'aime beaucoup que j'aimerais bien voir
quelqu'un comme stéphane plaza ça me
ferait énormément plaisir oui mais on
s'en fout un peu sur la musique on va se
calmer un peu c'est pas gladiator barre
des 100
[Applaudissements]
les gars se sont enflammés on m'a dit
ballon après si c'est pas dans le
domaine professionnel
attendez de ce qu'on a une question
d'une téléspectatrice l'espace bonjour
oui ça va lui faire plaisir que ça va le
mettre en relation des cultes quelque
chose une chose à vous répondre
mêlez vous de votre cul ça va lui faire
plaisir
gilles oui au drôle attention oui ça
n'est pas dans la sphère professionnelle
tirent eux qui rêveriez vous de voir ce
soir abc personnel alors si c'est
personnel il ya des gens qui me sont
chers ta maîtresse à ciboure des
affaires évoquées mais ça peut pas être
ma fille parce qu'elle est trop jeune et
penser ça quelqu'un c'est un peu ça peut
se pense pas que ce soit fatto donc dans
j'ai envie d'entendre fatou dans ça que
c'est pas tout mais non non je pense pas
que ce soit fatto franchement je pense
pas après je peux me tromper puis vous
vous vous allez vous dire cette personne
c'est une femme qu'elle est la première
femme à laquelle vous pensez mais la
vallière quelle est la première femme à
laquelle vous pensez
j'ai pensé à fatou j'ai pensé à ma fille
après il ya un an dans ma il ya une
troisième personne qui qui qui est
extrêmement cher évidemment mais mais
c'est impossible qu'elle soit là donc
c'est ma mère noël
oh non
que tu n'es qu'un étonnant
noël mamère série hollande
[Rires]
votre mère mais s'adapte ou votre mère
pardon elle habite ou votre mère elle
habite en seine et marne
vous êtes proche d'elle je suis très
proche d'elle je suis fils unique je
suis très proche d'elle mais comme c'est
pas possible qu'elle soit là ne me
mettais pas une sorte de fausse joie ou
de pourquoi c'est pas possible il
l'animatrice parce que c'est pas
possible qu'elle soit là parce que l
même pas la manière dont je suis à la
télé c'était pareil dans le foot et
c'est pareil dans touche pas à mon poste
elle aime pas me regarder parce qu'elle
me trouve trop agressif donc sa pâle
yolande haute mer ouais alors quel âge
elle a 80 ans gilles il ya quelqu'un
quelques questions vous posez on va
ouvrir le rideau
c'est quelqu'un de très proche ouvrez le
rideau ba ouvrait ce [ __ ] de rideau se
voit pas pour le moment c'est bien sévi
[Applaudissements]
au mans
alors
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'hollande de langue assez
l'évangile yolande vous êtes venus merci
d'être là déjà très très heureuse moi
aussi sèche
j'aime énormément chine c'est quelqu'un
que j'aime vraiment énormément et je
suis très heureux de vous rencontrer
gilles et très très émue roues oui si tu
fais la maman merci avec des fleurs
ouais alors vous avez d'hollande alors
de l'événement j'avais une question à
poser à jill une question qui vous
turlupine depuis très longtemps
ce que vous le regarder à la télé ali
pourquoi quand des gardes pourquoi es-tu
ce méchant à la télévision pourquoi
est-ce que tu crées les télévisions
l'enquêté si tranquille où tu es avec
moi mais vous savez que quand elle
regarde une émission de télé le soir
comme vendredi dernier koh lanta le
lendemain matin ma mère elle m'appelle
amélie tu as vu comme c'était génial
collante dans l'émission et le lendemain
il en dit du midi mais non c'était nul
regarde c'était magouilles et tout ça et
pendant une heure elle va me convaincre
jean d'ipad majjad hors service et comme
ça pour toutes les émissions alors il
regarde plus la télé la peau je ne
regarde plus alors on va essayer de
remédier à ça ce soir
ah non gilles répondent à votre maman
mais moment parce que commencer
et parce que tu disais la même chose
dans le foot c'est pareil moi je vois le
côté noir biseautés cage c'est que tu
dirais oui je veux dénoncer les choses
tout ce qui ne va pas c'est que j'aime
pas qu'il ment calmement qui me servent
aussi à payer alors il vous est ainsi
kahn dans la vie et à del et vous
transformez c'est peu d'après nos gens
qui sont là qu'est ce que même les
directs dans la vie mais il est ils
disent qu'ils n'en voient mais il ne
crie pas ben il crie pas ce cépage bce -
crier d'ailleurs vous m'avez souvent
digestion killing de crier non non il
mettra jamais j'ai deux mots trier mois
à chaque fois je dis non mais parce que
je m'emporte pour pour dire ce que j'ai
à dire pour donner mes arguments parce
que ça m'énerve qu'ils aient des
injustices et je voulais dénoncer et tu
le sais bien mais des images nazies ça
alors j'ai tout vous à six mois à dire à
votre maman ce soir brahim de la vérité
oh maman tu sais que je t'aime nez la
bouche
enfin les inculpant fait simplement pas
laisser ma tribu
[Applaudissements]
franchement gilles est un garçon d'une
gentillesse dans les couloirs très jeune
amélie dans mes passions c'est un garçon
très très très gentil je suis très
heureux de vous rencontrer
parce que vraiment je pense que vous
devez avoir la même gentillesse que
gilles et plus gentil que moi c'est
quelqu'un sur qui on peut compter
mais je les aime beaucoup merci je vous
laisse vous faire un petit câlin
[Applaudissements]
ça m'énerve parce que comme elle j'ai
comme envie d'avoir la vie de yolande
yolande est ce que vous voulez que
maquillage il se marie avec fatou on
n'en peut plus alors ça je ne me suis
jamais mêlé de sa vie privée
bah parce que je vous inviterai minerai
votre main dans le sac après le mien
aussi si vous veniez en gagnant vous
faites étaient tous très bien les orages
à colmar
merci merci de l'ordre